إذا كنت تستخدم مضخة الأنسولين أو لدى شخص
تحبه مثل جهاز تنظيم ضربات القلب ، فاحصل على هذا
، تريد إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية أن تعرف أن هذه الأجهزة
يمكن اختراقها ، لكن جين تقول إن الأمر
يعتمد على عمر الأجهزة أو
ما تعرفه من الأشياء الفنية التي تديرها
.  ماذا
وهذا ما يثير القلق على الرغم من ماذا لو كان لديك جهاز جديد يحتوي على برنامج قديم ،
فهذا هو
السؤال بالضبط ويمكن لأي شخص التحكم فيه عن بُعد
وعندما أقول أي شخص
هذا هو الاقتباس من إدارة الغذاء والدواء ، فما هي
الأجهزة المناسبة  هو سؤالك الفوري
، لا تعرف إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية أن إدارة الغذاء والدواء تقول إننا
لا نعرف بالضبط عدد
الأجهزة المتأثرة أو ما هي الأجهزة المتأثرة ، فهم يعرفون فقط
أنهم استخدموا برنامج الطرف الثالث لشبكة IP التي
تعدها إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية (FDA) بأنهم يعملون
بجد على هذا الآن  نعم ، لقد
أشاروا إلى ما إذا كان قد حدث أو إذا كانوا
يعتقدون فقط أن البرنامج قابل
للاختراق هو ما قالوه الحمد لله
لقد حدث ذلك ، وآمل ذلك